hello everyone welcome to another
episode of Q&A about his the future of
Science and Technology I am still not in
my natural habitat so uh technical
things could go wrong here all right
let's see all kinds of questions that we
have uh saved up here one from pavl here
can AI be swallowed by more advanced AI
by feeding it virtual input the
motivation could be increased efficiency
of larger
AIS well let's see I mean the um the
question is
computation can do all kinds of things
the issue is to align computation with
the kinds of things that we humans care
about and want to do things with and the
main sort of idea in modern times is
sort of train the AIS with lots of
material made by humans and you know
there's maybe I don't know 5 billion
maybe 10 billion web pages that are sort
of reasonably human written May maybe if
you include all of the sort of hidden
stuff there's maybe a 100 billion Pages
worth of of things humans have written
there's there's zillions of videos
things like this there's lots of
material that kind of shows what we
humans care about and kind of Paints the
picture of the kind of human relevant
world and that's a that's a place where
if you want AIS to do kind of human
relevant things then you've got to kind
of feed them human relevant training
material that they will then imitate so
to speak if you want them to do things
that are related to for example the way
the physical world works then having
them observe the physical world and say
oh I've I've grown up you know learning
about how chemical reactions work or how
proteins fold or something like this and
that's my experience of things there's a
question it's not completely obvious to
what extent the kind of the idea of just
train with what's already known is
enough to tell you what will come next
so to speak with with a lot of the
things in the kind of human world what
we what we're finding is that we humans
possibly because our brains are not that
different from neuron Nets that are sort
of put into AIS that the things that
that kind of we care about and that we
are able to do are things that can
readily be reproduced by kind of a
trained uh you know a trained neuronet
kind kind of approach
whether that's true of the things that
exist in the physical world is much less
clear it's a little bit complicated
because there are things that are
intrinsic to the physical world where
the physical world is doing what it does
and there are aspects of the physical
world that we humans have decided we
care about like for example if we look
at I don't know clouds in the sky the
detailed shape of clouds is something
that we humans don't usually make much
comment on other than to say you know
that one looks like a chicken something
but we're we're um uh that's something
but on the other hand the question of
you know is it raining right now is
something that we humans notice and so
it could be the case that even though
the underlying physics that's making the
Billings of the clouds and so on is not
something that is readily aable so to
speak that is readily sort of
extrapolatable from from training data
that it's still the case that something
like will it rain or not is and that's
the part we humans care about so this
question about whether sort of things in
the in the physical world are what one
might call sort of aable um is is it
could be the case that at some intrinsic
level they're not in fact that's my
belief is that they're not for all sorts
of reasons but that it's possible that
the ones of human relevance are more
likely to be I'm not clear whether they
are or aren't but that's not something
to to to ask about sort of the
underlying processes we're running into
this phenomenon of computational
irreducibility that I seem to talk about
a lot and that I kind of came up with in
the 1980s um this idea that just because
you know the rules for a system doesn't
mean you can immediately kind of jump
ahead and say everything about what the
system does you are in general have to
just go through sort of the irreducible
computational process of seeing each
step of what happens and if you're an AI
that that's sort of really trying to
just say is this something a bit like
what I've seen before oh then I know
what's going to happen that's not good
enough if if you have computational
irreducibility computational
irreducibility you have to follow the
steps and there will always be surprises
and those surprises will be things you
can't deduce from just saying well what
have I seen before let me train on what
I've seen before you know as a very
practical matter I was just looking
actually at um some the ability to
predict like computational processes
like cellular autometer with things like
neuron Nets Transformers all the fancy
technology and so on and the answer is
it does kind of sort of okay in some
cases and when things get complicated
and when sort of unexpected things start
to happen in these computational
processes the kind of the AI predictors
just sort of fall over and don't work
now you know there are all of questions
about what it's going to take to uh kind
of
get get to um uh to different levels of
kind of sort of humanlike performance I
mean that's a thing often of interest to
us humans is can we get an AI to do
humanlike
things again separate from can we have
the AI predict the positions of planets
or something at some point in the future
that is driven by physics the can we get
an AI to have humanlike performance on
telling apart pictures of cats and dogs
that's something where sort of the test
is can it emulate what we humans do not
can it follow what the physical world
does but again more complicated on the
quest of the physical world is often
what we want is not just the raw
physical world but the physical world as
perceived by humans in some way or
another so I think we can kind of ask
about all these different things about
what's possible and what's not I think
one of the things that was obviously the
big surprise of a bit more than a year
ago now was the whole chat gbt story of
gosh you can have an AI that produces
kind of pretty humanlike language and
sort of why does that work how does it
work and I think the realization is it
probably means that humanlike language
isn't as kind of complicated as we
thought it was it has more regularities
that we perhaps should be embarrassed
for not having noticed in the past and
and I think that same thing can be said
about a bunch of the places where sort
of there's been success in where where
the the AI has been able to sort of jump
ahead and do things that seemed magical
to us it's like well that's because we
didn't notice something that we could
have noticed that that human brains
could have dealt with we just didn't
happen to go in that
direction so you know there are there
are all sorts of questions about um uh
well all sorts of questions that that
raises like one one question is okay so
if the if the AI notices these sort of
regularities in the world that we didn't
notice in a sense science is about
recognizing those regularities so is it
possible that the AI can sort of uh find
regularities that will kind of build
drive forward science here's a couple of
issues with that one issue is it's one
thing to say yes I know what's going to
happen I have this black Black Box model
that I sort of Feed the input into a
neural net and it says it's going to the
answer is going to be three or something
that's sort of case number one where
it's kind of a blackbox thing case
number two is I can tell kind of a human
narrative or I can derive it's going to
be the number three with all kinds of
human steps inside there and I think
it's uh there are plenty of cases
particularly in technology where you
know getting that camera to focus
correctly on the on on the object of
interest in the image it doesn't matter
what the whether there's an explainable
algorithm for doing that that's not it's
something where once trying to achieve a
technological purpose that's that's what
we want it's I think less satisfactory
in some cases if you say well you know
why does this if if if you're trying to
have science be this kind of um this
this way of kind of taking what I what
science at some level natural science at
some fundamental level is is taking kind
of the complexity of the world and
figuring out how to make a narrative
based on that that sort of addresses the
main things that are going on in a way
that sort of fits in our finite Minds
that's kind of the the key activity of
natural science is to do that and in a
sense by saying well we just have this
black box which can say this is what's
going to happen but there's never going
to be a human level narrative about
about how that works isn't our
traditional view of how natural science
is supposed to be set up doesn't mean
it's not useful doesn't mean it's not
but but it's different from from what's
been done in kind of Natural Science as
it's evolved now it has to be said that
Natural Science as its evolved kind of
in a sense is is evading computational
irreducibility wherever you say well you
just have to run the system and see what
it does that's precisely saying there
isn't a narrative that that can be sort
of a reduced narrative that we get to
stuff in our brains that tells us what's
going to happen so I think this this
question about sort of
when when can we expect that sort of you
can just learn from experience and see
what's going to happen and whether you
can do that for systems in general or
for the aspects of systems that we
humans care about those are lots of
different kinds of questions and another
another isue is is is this maybe it's
the case that if you're using something
like a neural net and you're trying to
take all of this uh sort of data about
what happens in the world and you're
effectively making a model for that you
know in a in a in a vastly simpler case
when you make a model for something you
might fit a mathematical formula to some
data and you might say that's our model
in the case of a neural net you might be
fitting in the end you are fitting a
mathematical formula to the data but
it's a formula with a 100 billion
parameters in it or something and it's a
formula that has a particular structure
that corresponds to this neuronet and
and there kind of the question of well
if you have a model of that kind sort of
how big a model do you need to be able
to fit this or that kind of thing so for
example let's say we we're talking about
mathematical formula models that's often
the domain of Statistics it's kind of
like oh is it is this thing fit by two
gussian distributions or something you
know a formula that involves let's say
you know four parameters or something
like that that is is that a decent fit
to what we're seeing you know can we say
I don't know I don't know why I'm
thinking of this case but the law of
friction for example you know f equals
uh the MU * n you know it's a linear law
the frictional force is linearly
dependent on the normal force that's a
very simple model it's not precisely
correct but it's a good approximation in
many for many purposes and the fact that
that whole collection of sort of
physical phenomena is modelable with
that simple linear formula is a is is an
interesting fact now the question is if
you say well let's take human language
for example how big a formula do we need
effectively to do predictions to model
human language as human language is is
uh um is is typically used and the
answer we know from chat gbt is with 200
billion parameters we can do a
reasonable job of of sort of essay
writing type human language
activities and there's sort of a
question of of is that how does that
that 200 billion parameters or something
how does that uh kind of relate to what
human language is and for instance could
it be the case that there is sort of a a
a point of Threshold at which you
suddenly start to be able to do human
language like things oh if we we only
had 10 billion parameters we'll never
get there and and so on now there's a
little bit of kind of um circumstantial
evidence about these kinds of things so
if you look at the history of machine
learning for example there have been
these particular times when sort of
major advances were made that sort of
vaguely corresponded to the amount of
training time the size of the neuron
Nets these kinds of things the the sort
of the early efforts in doing you know
can we recognize
uh you know digits from 0 to 9 uh that
was you know 1980s and so on even
earlier than that can we recognize you
know 5,000 different kinds of images
that was 2011 2012 um what you know
they're these thresholds that seem to be
somewhat associated with the sizes of
networks and the amounts of training
data and so on and so one of the things
that's obviously an interesting
speculation is if you want to get to the
point of having reasonable human
language like stuff there's a threshold
I I tend to think the threshold is
considerably lower than the 200 billion
parameters because that happens to sort
of package in a lot of detailed
knowledge about the world that you don't
really need to have good sort of Common
Sense uh kind of linguistic capability
but maybe it's a tenth of size maybe
it's uh you know 50th the size it's it's
probably not uh a million parameters
that's probably not not enough so then
the question would be if we look at kind
of the history of biology and we say
okay you know the great achievement of
our species from a couple hundred
thousand years ago or whatever was we
got human language and notably another
great feature of our species we got a
bunch more brain a bunch more neurons in
our brains and more structure in our
brains and you know is it is it is it
conceivable that there is a threshold at
which you can have sort of reasonable
human language I don't know I think that
you could ask the question you know
typical human languages have you know
30,000 40,000 uh words in them that that
get used I think that's true of of all
human languages I'm not sure um I think
that's true of the the what 7,000 or so
extent human languages I think that's
true of of all of them uh now there are
sort of constructed languages that have
many fewer words but there are fewer
things you can say about the world with
those with those constructed languages
you can even have ones down to a couple
hundred words and you can have a kind of
General Pleasant discussion with those
languages but you can't have a I mean
for example the the conversation we're
having right now would not really be
accessible to a language with 200 words
in it now you know it raises the
question of if we scaled up if we had a
language with a million words could we
express a lot more kinds of things than
we can express in our language with
40,000 words or whatever could we you
know could it be the case that in so far
as we might talk about philosophy with
our 40,000 word language if we had a
million word language that we could have
a completely different level of of
discourse about
things well I don't think we know but
you know there is this this possibility
that for example getting to kind of
reasonable human language requires some
threshold and maybe there's another
threshold higher up where we get to
something sort of a sort of superhuman
language you could argue both ways on
this I think one argument against it
would be the phenomenon the principle of
computational equivalence phenomenon of
universal computation and so on that's a
place where you want to if you want to
sort of get something that can do
arbitrary computation you say well I've
got to add all these capabilities to the
system and I've got to make a you know a
touring machine you know we we know from
my efforts and and so on from the mid
2000s and and um this this prize that we
had for you know is this touring machine
the simplest possible Universal touring
machine answer yes we know that the
simplest possible uh sort of touring
machine that can do arbitrary
computation is this absolutely tiny
thing uh with two states and three
colors so but sort of there's this
question of once you've got to the point
where you can do Universal computation
then there's no further sort of
fundamental computational sophistication
you can get beyond that and in fact you
know it could be the case that if you're
trying to do these things let's say with
an interet that's incredibly inefficient
and that theet has to just go sort of
you know do all sorts of handstands and
so on to uh you know and and uh Cascades
of handstands so to speak to be able to
get to the point of doing what if you
represented in a slightly different way
would be a rather straightforward piece
of structure so to speak but that you
know but that so the argument would be
once the neuron net by all kinds of
stuff has been able to get to this sort
of universal computation point then
computationally it's it's in principle
able to go further actually neural Nets
aren't good Universal computers in the
way they're usually used because there's
this kind of one of the features of
universal computers is they can kind of
run with arbitr much m
and for arbitrarily long and that the
typical architecture of NE that's right
now at least doesn't doesn't have that
capability but so the question would be
the phenomenon we see there is that with
universal computation we get to this
threshold and once you're above this
threshold there's no further you can go
and it could be the case that with
things like language human language and
so on that the same thing is true once
you're above that threshold you can yes
you can add more words to the language
and you can get more specialized you Cam
more jargon and so on but fundamentally
you're there in terms of being able to
have sort of an expression of thoughts
that has the sort of this
compositionality of thoughts can Nest
within other thoughts and so on and that
you're kind of uh that there's no
further you can go or it could be that
you know if we had a million words we'd
be able to sort of get to very different
places I think what we can see is uh
there's there's a question of
quantitative versus qualitative change
what we can see is that as we kind of
formalize things with for example
computational language World from
language effort so to speak as we try
and sort of formalize the world in
computational terms which has been our
like last four decades effort to try and
represent the world in this kind of
computational way that it is certainly
something as a practical matter where
you can build much taller towers with
that kind of formalized structure than
you can if you're kind of just um uh
sort of um uh just just using sort of
plain language and so on it allows you
to to know that your Tower is not going
to fall over you don't you know the the
foundations are solid the bricks are are
hard so to speak as as you as you build
the thing up so you know I think uh
another thing to to sort of
Wonder well there's all these questions
about sort of when we look at the future
of let's say science you know to what
extent is AI going to and this kind of
neuronet idea and so on to what extent
is that going to
change uh provide change to to what's
possible in science it's worth saying
there are things that are the the the
whole using computation to represent and
formalize ideas that turn into science
that's clearly a winning thing and that
has you know that has a long way to run
so to speak and there are pieces to that
once you formalize things
computationally there are kinds of
things you can do that you couldn't do
before like you could say something like
let's enumerate all possible theories of
this let's enumerate all possible
systems that do this or that that that
have this or that structure this is the
area that I like to call rology the
study of simple rules let's say and what
they could possibly do or equivalently
let's enumerate all possible chemical
structures and see whether any of them
do this or that thing let's enumerate
all possible algorithms of this type
let's see whether any of them do the
thing we want that idea of kind of
rology and exploring the computational
universe it's not a very aiish thing
because it's mostly it's a thing where
you're really just Computing out there
but um perhaps then the question is can
AI help you to figure out when you're
searching this big space of
possibilities can it help you to say
that's a more fertile area than that and
so on that's one thing it could do
another thing it could do is be able to
say once you've got a candidate thing oh
I can predict more quickly that that's
hopeless or that's interesting to look
at I mean this type of thing you know
there are endless efforts to do drug
design for example using sort of aiish
methods where you're enumerating and
sometimes you're enumerating sometimes
you're you're selecting I don't think I
mean you could you can use the um the AI
in a sense it's very easy to get the AI
to be creative because you know you just
throw a random number and you say let's
put the molecules in this put the atoms
in this configuration and let's see
whether that's a candidate now the
question is are you are you are you
arranging it so that whichever way the
dice comes down you'll always get a
viable C candate or at least a plausibly
viable candidate and for that it matters
sort of what the underlying model of
what these molecules might be like is
and if you set the parameters up
correctly then whatever however you pick
them you're going to get a reasonable
molecule and that's a sort of aiish
thing to do to kind of figure out what's
a reasonable parameterization so that
you can then drive it with rology
effectively um and and just start
enumerating things so
you know I think there there are
questions like that I mean I think
another type of question is if you're
solving math problems like there was
recent announcement about geometry
problems doing geometry proofs um if you
uh sort of if you say well let's you
know is there a point at which human
geometry proofs are kind of yeah we kind
of know how to do those because we've
seen enough examples that we can kind of
piece the pieces together and for the
level of things that are human relevant
we can just say yes you know we we've
seen enough examples we can just see
what to do I think the uh the question
of sort of can you always do well
geometry is a special case because
geometry is a decidable mathematical
Theory ukan geometry is which means in
principle you can just for example turn
it into algebra problem we can do that
in W language and Mathematica you can
sort of turn it into algebra problem you
just grind it and you can get to a
result in a in a it might take a while
but you know you can do it there are
plenty of other places in mathematics
even in arithmetic you say I've got this
equation that involves just integers and
it is you know X Cub + y cubal z Cub
plus whatever and say find X Y and Z so
that satisfy this equation there is no
upper bound uh in General on on how far
you have to look to do that it's a
that's a undecidable theory and and so
that's a thing where you can't guarantee
if if you say well uh you know is is it
conceivable that I could just sort of
close this off by finding enough sort of
rules for how to do it and that then I'd
always be able to do it in limited time
the answer is no you you can't do that
so but I mean there's this question of
if you want to achieve sort of human
level performance on some particular
task to to what extent sort of how how
many parameters of uh do you need to be
able to do that how much training
material do you need to be able to do
that and so on and to what extent are
there kind of thresholds of uh of oh it
doesn't work at all versus it's sort of
achieved human level or something um and
you know you might have thought this was
a surprise with things like chat gbt you
might have thought that as you kind of
added more neurons or whatever else
added more training data the thing would
progressively get better but in fact
that's not our experience in fact our
experience is it was really crummy until
it reached above a threshold and then it
looked really good now is that a
phenomenon of the thing itself or is
that more a phenomenon of our perception
I mean it's kind of like you could say I
don't know this is uh uh what's a good
example I mean you know when something
kind of is good enough enough that we
can really use it versus it's
um uh it's kind of a little bit too
crummy uh what is a good example of that
there must be plenty in in sort of
mechanical kinds of things I don't know
if you have a um uh uh an automatic
screwdriver or something where the thing
doesn't quite have you know enough uh
you know can't quite exert enough torque
to be able to you know screw that screw
SC in or something it's like well that
was nice but it doesn't quite make it
for the purposes I have because typical
screws in a piece of wood or something
require this amount of force and it
doesn't really quite make it and so I
might as well just throw that device
away um and as soon as it's above the
critical torque level then it's like
okay great it's going to work and and it
could be the case that that you know we
we don't really have a good sense for
something like language of what that
kind of what that thresholding looks
like
my own guess is that there are certain
once you've achieved once you've leared
certain regularities you're above that
threshold like for example I could be
below the threshold where I knew basic
grammar and I could be continually
making up sentences which are just
grammatically wrong you know cat dog
chase Mouse I don't know cat dog red big
was okay it's it's uh you know we can in
some language that that word order might
be fine but but you know I can clearly
make up sentences which you immediately
know are wrong because they just violate
standard syntactic grammar in English
for example and there will be a point at
which that no longer happens where it's
syntactically correct um and uh uh that
you know whether and how that threshold
works is is not clear you know I think I
was yaking on here about a lot of things
and not really even addressing the
question that was being asked which was
I think about um feeding sort of the
next level of AI uh things that were the
experience of the previous level of AI
and you know I think that is both an
opportunity and a danger so to speak I
mean in the sense that right now we are
getting AIS that do human relevant
things because we train them on human
produced stuff by the time we're
training them on AI produced stuff we've
got this sort of strange uh sort of
Dynamics where you know the AI thing is
if the a thing was exactly a perfect
model for humans then training on AI
based stuff will be equivalent to
training on humans and it's all good but
assume that the AI based stuff isn't
quite equivalent to humans for example
let's say we've got essays and for
whatever reason intrinsic or kind of
control the essays of very Bland that
the AI produces and then the next
generation of AIS are trained only on
very Bland essays well obviously then
over the course of time as we train more
and more levels of AIS things just get
blander and blander and yeah they won't
say anything wrong they might say almost
nothing they might just have platitudes
so to speak but um but that would be
sort of the the direction so I think
it's probably true that anytime One is
using some sort of one is modeling what
the original sort of underlying training
data was one is making one sort of
acting as some kind of modeler Observer
whatever of that original training data
the the the kinds of things that you're
doing to to be able to model those
things are sort of reducing that
training data it's not the whole
training data you've made decisions
you've you've got what amount to biases
uh not biases of of social or ethical
relevance necessary neily they might be
but just ones that the model was of this
kind and so it tended to do this or that
thing and then you amplify that by going
to more and more levels and then it's
more about what was yeah I think this is
the point it's more about what was in
the model than it was what was in the
original data in other words if you
iterate many levels of you know you're
going to train from the from the results
of the model that was trained from the
results of the model and so on pretty
soon your reflecting the model more so
than reflecting the underlying training
data or possibly reality now you know
you can imagine that in sort of the the
uh the training of AIS let's say you're
trying to get them to train on what the
physical world is like maybe they're
robots maybe they can go and make
measurements about the physical world
maybe they've got grounding in reality
in the real physical world that they can
go and and and mine more training data
effect i l from the physical world it's
us humans have only produced a certain
amount of stuff you know you could
imagine some some terrible scenario
where sort of the AIS have decided that
they just need more training data from
the humans and in some kind of strange
inverse Matrix type setup you know the
AIS have just hooked up a bunch of
brains and the AI just sort of poking
those brains just saying we want more
training data we want to see what do
this brain do in that scenario what does
it do in that scenario let's go explore
all these different things and you have
this sort of brain bank that is that is
driving that is providing the ground
truth so to speak for the AIS as the AIS
might have ground truth provided by
going and exploring the physical world
for example so that's a that's a a
rather awful scenario I think from our
point of view now I mean you might say
gosh you know if AI is going to be the
next evolutionary level in the
development of uh our sort of well I
don't know whether it's a biosphere but
but um the development of uh uh of of
sort of the future of us or something
that gosh you just want the AI to be as
well trained as possible to carry as
much of kind of the the human
achievement as can be carried into sort
of the the future of of what exists um I
think it's uh um I don't know as as a as
just a simple human myself I I tend to
be rather uh uh human- centered so to
speak and and rather uh not uh you know
the idea of of and I suppose it relates
to a lot of sort of in a sense both per
personal and societal purpose so to
speak is it you know does one think it's
okay you know if the if a civilization
wrote down all its great discoveries and
they were passed down through the ages
but the civilization was exterminated uh
you know is that is that okay or does
one feel bad about that I I kind of
think as sort of a as a human one feels
bad about that um as a sort of looked at
from the outside whatever that means
because I don't think it means much you
could say look you've got more knowledge
more abstraction more abstract kinds of
things that were produced even though
sorry the actual humans that produced it
are long gone um you know it really
depends on and it sort of it quickly
devolves into questions and this is
going to go sort of deep philosophy or
something into questions about sort of
the purpose of the universe and if it
has one which I don't think it
meaningfully can be said to have one um
but uh you know this question of whether
whether it's sort of good enough to have
these kind of engrams of of abstract
achievement or whether what matters is
the details of the actual humans and I
think the uh uh sort of it quickly
devolves into meaninglessness if you say
that what is going to be left is just
the engram so to speak without the
actual humans and their experiences you
know I think it's uh yeah so that um
uh yeah so I mean this question about if
you if you let the AIS train the AIS and
so on my claim would be actually sort of
interesting inter in interesting thing
because okay in in biology there are
sort of forces of natural selection that
are informed by the world as it is you
know if the climate gets warmer and
things like that there will be changes
to the sort of forcing function of what
is a successful species and so the
species through natural selection will
tend to evolve sort of fixed to the
ground truth of the actual physical
environment of the earth uh for now at
least until we get species on Mars
evolving and things like this or on the
atmosphere of Venus that's a more
interesting case I would say um but in
any case we can imagine some interesting
kind of uh natural artificial selection
of let's let's make microbes that live
in the in the Clouds of Venus and so on
and perhaps do interesting things or
things we think are interesting to them
but okay so in biological evolution
there's sort of a ground truth from the
uh the physical environment there's also
a certain set of constraints associated
with kind of the way biological
organisms are put together you know
unless you're going to jump away from
proteins and things it's we're fixed we
we have a certain set of constraints
about what can happen unless we you know
it's pretty hard for organisms to make
Wheels I mean bacteria have little fella
at the back and so on but fundamentally
you don't see a lot of big organ isms
running around on or Wheeling around on
Wheels uh because that isn't something
it's particularly easy to make with you
know blood supplies and nerves and all
this kind of thing so it's um uh there
are these constraints about the
construction of the organism and there
are constraints that are imposed by sort
of the environment now it could be the
case that being a wheel organism would
be a fantastic thing for some
environment that that arises but you
probably won't get there because it's
just not something that can be
constructed from the components you have
but I think an interesting thing with
sort of the AI story here is if you say
train from the train you know train
train train in a big in a big train of
training so to speak that you um will
end up with something which is much more
dependent on the underlying constraints
of the construction of the AI than on
the external environment if you keep
going back to the external environment
and saying what can we deduc from sort
of the ground truth of the external
environment that's more like what has
happened in biological evolution so far
I mean by the way we can imagine a
similar situation in biological
evolution if we're if we're evolving you
know in a Petri dish or maybe even in in
tumors and humans I'm not sure where
where sort of it's in an environment
where the environment is sort of fixed
and you don't get to sort of go back and
ask more about the environment and it's
that that then it's more something which
is strained by the intrinsic nature of
the thing that's evolving so to speak
rather than by what's sort of imposed by
the environment but so my guess would be
if you go the sort of the chain of of
trainings of of AIS that in the end it
will be more and more evident that oh
you using a Transformer with this and
that and the other characteristics in
the in the in the system now you can say
well how about if you evolve the the the
architecture of the neur net sure you
can do that I think then you will be
recursing again to saying well what was
the evolver of the architecture of the
neural net and so on I think unless you
you get to sort of external ground truth
I think that you are inevitably going to
evolve it the interesting thing to
actually study in detail to evolve to
something which tends to be uh kind of
uh uh which which tends to reflect the
sort of inner construction
mechanism okay that was a super long
answer to that let's
see
uh well okay let's there's a whole bunch
of questions and comments about AI here
let me try and address some of these but
X asks do you think anyone will solve
the rean hypothesis in your lifetime
let's let's talk about that for a minute
and we'll talk about whether the someone
might be an AI what that would mean etc
etc etc reminder about the ran hyp hthis
formulated around what 1860 or so by
Bernard rean the uh rean hypothesis is
about this thing called the rean zeta
function and as it's stated it's are all
of the zeros places where Zeta of of uh
s is equal to zero are all of those at
places where on the critical line um uh
s equals a half plus I times a times an
arbitary variable where I is squ minus
one so that's that's what the the thing
is it's stated in terms of this sort of
mathematical construct what it really is
about is the randomness of prime numbers
it's really something that relates to
the density of prime numbers and really
the rean hypothesis asks is there a
certain degree of Randomness in the
distribution of primes if there is that
then the re hypothesis is true if there
isn't that then there's certain
regularities that we didn't think
existed that um uh with within the
Primes and um I think the when you look
at the zeta function you sort of plot it
out and you see it wiggling it Wiggles a
lot and the ran hypothesis is equivalent
to is when it looks at these Wiggles is
there ever a a minimum
wiggle a lowest point that's above the
axis that's
above value equals
zero okay so you when you see it
wiggling you realize this might be a
hard thing to figure out because there's
a lot of complicated Wiggles there now
the real question though is what would
it mean to figure it out you know it
really relates to questions about what
is mathematics and the the kind of last
century or so view has been mathematics
is based on you set down axioms you say
these are the things that I assume are
true you know uclid said that these are
the things I assume are true now let me
as a purely sort of mechanical process
see what I can derive from that now
that's a tricky thing because what do
you assume is true like uclid for
example assumed his fifth postulate
assumed that no parallel lines can ever
cross and that postulate turns out to be
well it's a fine thing to assume you can
do geometry on that basis as a as a
constructive kind of thing but it turns
out it's not true for the physical
Universe in the physical universe space
can be curved that was sort of the
discovery of general relativity and uh
that um that means that uet's axioms are
just sort of this bubble out there
that's not related as such to physical
reality and you can invent different
axioms for mathematics and you can say
well somebody could say well I've got
the rean hypothesis and I'm going to
choose these axioms for mathematics that
include very obscure things about
infinite sets and how they work and so
on and it's like okay with these AXS of
mathematics Kaboom we proved the rean
hypothesis you say well you know that
was or for example worst case in in
areas of theoretical computer science
people sometimes assume the rean
hypothesis so you could say well I'm
going to make an axiim system and I'm
going to get something which is you know
almost assuming the rean hypothesis then
if I prove the rean hypothesis like who
cares that was obvious so the real
question about proving the rean
hypothesis is you've got to go from some
axioms to prove the hypothesis now it
could be the case that the axium that
you typically use in mathematics for
let's say arithmetic or something that
those AXS are just not powerful enough
to prove or disprove the reman
hypothesis it could be the case that the
reman hypothesis is something where you
know you the the it's a thing where you
could with those axioms alone you just
don't reach that particular theorem
roughly it's a little bit more
complicated with reman hypothesis
because it has the feature that if you
can show that it is
undecidable then it is in some sense
true uh because of just the way that
it's stated in terms of for alls and
their exists and things like this but
but roughly it's it's fair to say that
sort of it depends what uh you know you
have to ask given this particular sort
of low-level formalization of
mathematics and by the way most
mathematics that's done is not done down
to its lowest level formalization for
example you know when format's Last
Theorem was proved you know that the
chap who proved it I asked him he said
what aims did you assume he says I have
no idea you know I just did it using
sort of common mathematics of the time
which is what everybody thought was the
interesting thing to do to say uh kind
of what would be the um uh you know to
say Can you can you just go mechanically
from certain axioms to prove that
theorem that's sort of a different level
of question not one of such interest to
most mathematicians I mean there are
efforts in modern times to make proof
assistance computational systems where
you're kind of fitting together puzzle
pieces and you're saying you know if you
can fit this puzzle this way then you
have definitively proved this thing but
it's a it's a really hard road to um uh
to be able to do that and then even when
you've done it it's not clear what
you've got because the it could be the
case that so so what you have to claim
is that something like the hypothesis
format's Last Theorem that there's a
gaggle of possible Axiom systems for
which that that a re reasonable axim
system makes the thing true and that you
could that if you tweaked the axim
system so that it wasn't true lots of
other stuff would fall apart but that's
a little bit of a trickier thing now it
could be the case that with the kind of
standard level mathematics that don't go
all the way down to these axim systems
that you could prove the ran hypothesis
and I don't have a good sense my my own
guess would be that you need to go down
to this infrastructure level that it
that it if in the end it has a
dependence on some infrastructure kinds
of things I will say about the ran
hypothesis there is a nice
correspondence um there is there are
sort of fairly simple to State
mathematical problems like the 3n plus
one problem you take a number if it's
even you divide it by two if it's odd
you say 3 n + 1 and then you ask the
question if you start off with any
number does that thing eventually
reach sort of small numbers it goes to
one and four and things like this or
does it sort of eventually go off and
get bigger and bigger if it always hits
the 3 n plus1 it's going to get bigger
and bigger if it hits the N over two
it'll go down to something smaller and
it bounces around you can make these
plots they bounce around all over the
place so it turns out there's a
formulation of the rean hypothesis as
partly due to well most of the real work
um done by a chap called Yuri Mattis
savich long-term user of technology uh
who's been involved in proving lots of
lots of interesting things about uh kind
of what's decidable and what's not um
but anyway he he kind of made a a
version of the r hypothesis which can be
stated in terms of these sort of
iterations involving inges I tried to
clean it up a bit got a simpler version
um which actually see I think seemed to
people some point so bizarre that um uh
you know how could this possibly be be
right but um but I think it is um and
it's just you know it's a one line of w
language code and just says if this
iteration n goes to blah blah blah um if
that iteration doesn't uh if that
iteration always terminates then the
reman hypothesis is true and so you've
you've reduced it to this problem about
sort of iteration of integers and that
kind of makes it a little bit more kind
of it brings it a little bit closer to
these kinds of questions that are more
about kind of going down to the low
levels of axioms and a little little bit
less about kind of can we construct this
nice geometrical picture that allows us
to use sort of traditional mathematics
to go and um uh to go and work through
uh different kinds of
things so I think the answer is my guess
would be that the r hypothesis might be
proved to be uh undecidable from certain
ACC Sims that's a thing that might
happen uh you know fairly soon to know
kind of the narrative
story uh you know from sort of some
common idea of mathematics that isn't as
such the axioms I think that's a more
challenging
thing let's
see
uh oh was there's a there's a question
here from Jamie will AIS um okay let me
take a quick quick comment here from RBS
aren't there thousands and thousands of
Papers written that assume the reman
hypothesis is true yes absolutely there
are and um and
uh let's see I mean
the the status of those many of them are
algorithmic papers that say this
algorithm will be correct this
randomized algorithm will be correct if
whatever and and my guess is I haven't
really thought this through properly but
but my guess is that this whole question
about what aims you're assuming to get
the result H that probably relates to
particularly when it's randomized
algorithms that probably Tangles itself
up with where did the randomness come
from that you say well I pick these
things at random and with overwhelming
probability probability that approach is
one this or that will happen that
somehow the atiz of that random
randomness will be sort of entangled
with the aimation you're using to prove
the hypothesis that that's that would my
guess about how that will
work
um let's see Jamie's asking will AIS be
the ones to explore
space well I mean it depends I think
that um
uh you know
in space is very not very human friendly
it's the time scales you know the speed
of light compared to and the distances
between Stars compared to human
lifespans it doesn't look good um and uh
uh it's you know you want to get to the
nearby star it's going to take you many
current human lifetimes to do that and
so well what do you do well you can sort
of dehumanize the humans at some level
you can say okay let's let's you know
make the thing that's worked in science
fiction forever but we don't yet know
how to make work in practice you know
cryonic suspension so to speak let's
let's make that work and then sort of we
we kind of uh uh you know we we freeze
the humans and then they wake up in
50,000 years and they're at alpha centur
or something um and uh you know in a
sense that's a uh uh you know in that
sense yes the humans can explore space
if if we manage to make that technology
work which my guess is one will be able
to I think it will be non-trivial to
have the you know the Interstellar dust
part interplanetary yeah Interstellar
dust particles that you know hit the
spacecraft not you know over the course
of 50,000 years or whatever not destroy
any material we put in place but let's
assume that's also solvable let's assume
there's little robots that go fix things
and things but in a sense it's like well
yeah we got a human
TFA centur in 50,000 years and and so
what so to speak and we could also say
well we got some kind of AI to Alpha
centor in 50,000 years and again it
might be a so what because it's it's um
uh the you know this relates to sort of
again to these things we were talking
about before about you know you can
create a thing computationally you can
do a thing but does it relate to
anything that we humans actually care
about I mean I think that uh it's worth
remembering that the the the the one way
that we get to kind of explore the
universe without going to all that
trouble is through things that go at the
speed of light whether it's uh light
itself whether it's gravitational waves
whether it's maybe neutrinos that go at
least really close to the speed of light
um these are things where they uh kind
of you know they there are ways to sort
of see different parts of the universe
without physically going there in other
words how important is it to see with
your own eyes Alpha Cantor versus how
important is it versus can you if you
get photons from there that we can
receive here you know is that is that a
thing one can do and then uh you know I
think it's it's worth remembering it's
kind of ironic that for a photon because
it's going at the speed of light and
time is infinitely dilated at the speed
of light to a photon no time passes you
know from the time the photon is emitted
to the time the photon is absorbed
that's you know just a moment there's no
no time has passed so photons that were
emitted right at the beginning of the
universe or at the point where the
universe became transparent 100,000
years or something after it began um
where there are photons that are just
sort of going through
through coming towards us and event some
Photon from the cosmic microwave
background that lasted 14 billion years
of our time and finally got absorbed by
some detector you know it seems feels
very sad that it lasted 14 billion years
and then Splat we detected it in some in
some uh uh detector of microwave
radiation that to the photon no time
will have passed to the photon if the
photon was kind of uh if if we had some
kind of assembly of things that was uh
sort of if we could imagine a mind made
of photons so to speak then no time
would pass for that mind between the
creation of the mind and the destruction
of the mind so to speak at a time which
for our minds is is is vastly later so
you know I think there's this question
of sort of we're going to explore the
universe we're going to send out sort of
AI probes they will kind of go out and
about in the universe and they'll arrive
places 100,000 years from now or
something you know I don't know that's a
that's a complicated issue what what how
one feels about that I mean it's kind of
like building the pyramids and putting
things in there that were sort of
intended for the afterlife but end up
being relevant for 4,000 years later and
you know how do you feel about that you
know that process of putting things out
there into into the Universe I have a
number of friends who've been involved
in sort of putting things out into the
universe so we at least have planted our
flag on the UN Universe even long after
we might be around or or not around and
so on so I think it's um uh but if if
one's asking the question you know for
example within our solar system uh you
know will it be the case that it's um we
can have robotic spacecraft going and
exploring things surely the answer is
yes um there is a certain sort of
coolness factor to having the actual
humans show up on mars or whatever else
rather than just oh it's a Rob IC probe
and it's sending data back and we can
get you know even if we can get very
high bandwidth data back from it it
still feels cooler and feels more us
related if there's you know a friendly
human so to speak who went there rather
than just a robotic probe but I think
you know it's clearly vastly easier to
have uh I mean you know it depends a bit
on one's view about sort of the value of
humans versus the value of robots versus
whatever else I mean if you know in some
uh to my mind very undesirable world
where you know you say well humans
aren't that valuable we can send a bunch
of them off to Mars maybe some of them
will make it and you know they're cheap
so to speak you know that would be a
different world than than fortunately
than the one we seem to live in where
it's uh you know where the calculation
of what you know what's it plausible to
do is is different I mean there are
plenty of places in the world to today
where it's like well we could have a
factory robot do that but why bother
because we can have a human do it sort
of uh for the same price type thing and
I think you know you can you can imagine
the same kinds of things with respect to
robotic probes versus humans and in so
far as you put sort the value of of
human prosperity in life for the
astronauts or whoever else very very
high um you know it makes it much more
attractive to to send the robot out
where yeah it's you know it's kind kind
of just money if it blows up so to
speak let's
see
uh yeah well IBS is commenting you know
if if
only if only we could just send okay if
on Alpha centor we had a sort of
friendly Cooperative whatever where we
just send a light signal out out there
and then a 3D printer starts up on Alpha
centur and makes the thing that we want
to make and then it goes and you know
does its study of whatever we want to
study and it sends back this wonderful
picture of this totally alien thing that
we don't recognize as anything like life
or whatever else some complicated
chemical process that we say huh that's
that's kind of interesting you know I
wonder what that means so to speak um
yes but I I think um
uh that that's
um that's kind of a we don't have a way
to do that you know it's an interesting
question whether we could in a sense
whenever we well
okay right now we are taking passive
information from for example exoplanets
you know there's light from a star it
maybe goes through the atmosphere of the
exoplanet maybe we get some wonderful
spectroscopic conclusion from that but
we're not and we're far from being able
to say let's shine a laser in the
direction of that exoplanet wait eight
years or something and see what comes
back we're not in a position to do that
the energetics of that don't work out
even close right now I mean the the
fundamental problem there is if we could
keep a beam of light sort of perfectly
columnated then we might be able to do
that but we can't because of the
phenomenon of defraction it's inevitable
that it will spread out and we can't and
so that idea that then we have to put a
incredible power into it so that even
with the sort of inverse Square LW of it
spreading out we'll still get something
reasonable back I mean to give an
example of actually probably the the the
sort of the furthest out active things
like that are you send a a signal to a
you know the the um uh which one is it
Voyager is still in contact or Pioneer
Voyager I think um Voyager yeah so you
know you can send a signal out to the
Voyager spacecraft and it will do
something and you get data back that's
kind of like we put the 3D printer on
Alpha centur except it isn't even close
to to Alpha centur yet but so the
question would be is there a way without
having without humans having put
something at the place where you're
having a receiver could you imagine a
situation where there's a thing out in
the distance so so to speak that could
receive a light signal and do the the
useful thing with it and then send the
data back we don't know how to do that
right now and but that's I mean one
could imagine that and that would kind
of that would
definitely make it uh even less sort of
attractive to send out that human-built
piece of material stuff I mean in a
sense what one's proposing doing is
sending out human-built photons but
rather than human-built physical objects
with little pieces of metal and so on
and
them let's
see
uh you know I mean I have to say in our
models of
physics the to us right now photons look
like featureless you've either got one
or you don't in our models of physics
photons are probably made of this kind
of complicated structure made of this
network that represents the structure of
space and the structure of everything in
the universe it's kind of like saying
I've got an Eddie in my water and I can
see that Eddie and it's just an Eddie
but that Eddie is ultimately made of a
bunch of molecules underneath and so one
could imagine that sort of a photon
right right now we only think the only
thing that matters about a photon is its
energy and its momentum that's the you
know the only thing that distinguishes
one Photon for another is its energy and
its momentum there's no labeling of a
photon beyond that
and um well actually that's more in well
okay that that's that's basically a fair
statement the um it's a little
complicated which is the photon and that
that um you'll end up with two of them
and they have different effects and so
on and the question is they exist
physically or do they exist in bronchial
space and that's the whole story of
quantum mechanics and so on so that gets
complicated but in a first approximation
sort of a photon is a photon and it's
kind of like a black hole in current
theories of physics it's kind of like a
a black hole all you all that matters is
essentially the same thing energy
momentum and there's a few other
parameters that that matter as well the
spin and the charge and so on but but to
the outside of the black hole that's all
that matters inside the black hole it
could be the case there was some whole
civilization that was you know whose
planet was crushed by some collapsing
star and so on and that's inside the
black hole but from the out side you
don't see any of that and might be the
same way with photons uh maybe that's
there's no way of of sort of cracking
open the nut of the photon so to speak
and seeing what's inside in the case of
black holes we think that quantum
mechanics in some sense can crack open
the nut and see what's inside um and and
that that um and so this question of
okay you've packaged things in a photon
that's going at the speed of light and
so on you know is it possible you could
sort of crack open that nut and um uh
and see more detail about it that's I
mean it's faintly conceivable given our
models of physics it's certainly
something far away from what we know how
to do at the present time um or even
sort of uh it's it's um I mean it's this
question of are all photons really the
same um and you know right now we don't
have any way to distinguish them um and
uh the um but that's that will be one
possibility that will be one bizarre
possibility for a sort of additional
channel of communication I I'm I I don't
hold out that much hope for that but I
think that's a conceivable thing I mean
something people are always commenting
on is when it comes to you know uh have
we met the aliens so to speak and I I
always think that's an a very poor
question because the details of us
humans if yes if there was something in
the Galaxy that was just another you
know humanoid like carbon life form type
thing we meet them and we say yes you're
a human Carbono humanoid carbon life
form or something we recognize what it
is but you know if what it is is
something that involves chemical
reactions involving manganes and uh
niobium doing this and that and the
other and producing very complicated
patterns which to the inner experience
of the M magnesi manganes niobium thingy
is like look we have this amazing
civilization but we look at it and we
say that's some weird chemical reaction
which we don't understand and who cares
type thing so I tend to think that the
the sort of the the problem of sort of
alien finding is a problem that that
there are many complicated things going
on in the universe they're just in the
terms of our physics project for example
they're not close enough in Ral space to
us that we can readily interpret them
but in any case the the thing that's
often sort of a a staple for science
fiction and so on is imagine there's a
new way to communicate in the universe
which is basically saying imagine
there's a new feature of the universe
that we get to bring into our perception
like you know we've had eyes since the
trilobites or something I don't know
whatever it is you know a solid few
hundred million years uh you know life
on Earth has had eyes um but life on
Earth doesn't have neutrino detectors
life on Earth doesn't have gravitational
wave detectors we've built bu those
things as pieces of Technology our
species has built those things but
that's something where we get to see a
new feature of the universe when we do
that and one sort of one might imagine
okay well guess what if if only we had
managed to tap into the you know the
gravitational wave sort of internet then
sort of then we would discover the
aliens now in some sense things like
that are true because the this this
point that there's a lot of complicated
stuff going on in the universe and what
you notice depends on sort of how you
can do the noticing and so that's
something where you can expect yes you
know once you know about gravitational
waves and you can detect them and so on
you'll be able to see complex processes
going on in the universe that you
weren't otherwise able to see and you
could say well we've detected sort of
the alien
intelligence I I might say that you know
the weather on Earth is an alien
intelligence it doesn't happening very
close to our intelligence but it is
something that has the same kind of
computational complexity that um our our
brains
have let's
see it's a question from imagination
here do you think Ray csw's longevity
predictions are likely to happen in our
own lifetime haven't talked to Ray in
years actually um so I don't know I
don't know how he's doing on the
longevity
scale um but uh I remember having lunch
with him a number of years ago and um
the uh was impressed at the at the
number of pills of different kinds that
um he he took along with one piece of
lettuce or something so you know who
knows maybe that's a winning solution I
think that the um uh the question of
what will happen with sort of human
longevity is it's interesting one I mean
you know we've been in many countries
sort of the life expectancy has been
increasing by about a third of a year
per year for the last 70 years or so I
think most of that is cardiovascular
kinds of things that things which are
essentially mechanical people can detect
and so on I I tend to think and it's
certainly my own personal sort of uh
approach to this is the first step is
detect things you know do all those
tests make all those
measurements you know if they all say
it's all fine then you know assume it's
going to be fine but by doing all those
tests you get sort of an early warning
of what's going on I mean it's kind of
like how did airplanes or general
anesthesia two examples where sort of
there have been great advances in sort
of their effectiveness and uh uh and not
crashing and not not failing type type
thing over the course of years and and I
think the thing that's really been the
the Big Driver of those is better senses
better kind of awareness of what's going
on you know is the taale of your
airplane about to fall off well you know
you might have some sensor that would
tell you that rather than just you have
to wait and see what happens so I think
the um you know that that well like you
know metal fatigue detection or
something from from uh uh whatever but
but different different kinds of kinds
of
things but the point is so I think one
you know that that's surely a driver of
uh of longevity but it's not going to
solve the problem because that's just
saying you know detect things early
maybe you can patch them you can fix
them if you detected earlier um that
still is the case apparently that life
eventually wears out now at some level
you know there are plenty of organisms
where kind of that organism buds off
another piece and the bud kind kind of
keeps going and the organisms gone on
for a gazillion years the organism in
some sense you could say but it's not
the same organism but it isn't the same
of us either because you know our cells
are continually turning over okay there
are some cells like nerve cells that
don't turn over at least not at all
quickly um but you know the the the is
it us well you know our skin cells our
gut cells whatever else blood cells
they're all turning over fairly fairly
rapidly and being replaced by new new
cells and so you know I think there's
this question of but but we think you
know the part of us that is critical to
the usess of us is mostly brain type
things whether that's really the
ultimate story is not so clear I mean I
don't know how how much of the usess of
us depends on things other than brains
might depend on the endocrine system
might depend on the immune system might
depend on the gut microbiome who's to
say you know those things you say well
well those aren't really relevant but
they might change for example your
approach to life might be different
depending on sort of uh you know hormone
levels that are produced by something
that has little to do with the brain as
such so it it's not completely clear
what the package that you need to sort
of maintain the usess actually is but I
think the um uh when it comes to you
know maintaining the whole package that
um you know supports the brain and all
these other systems that's the question
is can can you do that and sort of uh
you know how will one increase longevity
well the first question is why do we age
to begin with and that's not completely
clear I mean it's you know there are
different sort of things that go wrong
and there are telome that fall off the
ends of DNA but then they can put them
back on again you know think the enzymes
can put them back on again then there
are sort of oxidative damage things
essentially just burning up and um there
are and there are sort of deposits of
this or that that get produced all kinds
of things there are sort of tangling of
the DNA there are all sorts of different
things that that um uh that go
wrong obviously they can be fixed
because when you go to the Next
Generation those things are
restarted and it's not obvious that you
can't take you
know the things that you have right now
and kind of restart them from stem cells
for example uh it's it's I mean there
are there's increasingly increasing
success in kind of taking sort of well
first thing was taking a cell that
exists you know some random skin cell or
something and reverting it back to
something that will be a cell that can
differentiate into anything just like
our original uh you know fertilized egg
or something cell can differentiate into
all of us so to speak and so that's um
uh you know it's it's clear that it is
possible to turn the clock back because
it happens with every successive
generation so now the question is can
you sort of turn the clock back within
an organism you know in a sense can you
rebuild the plane even as the plane is
flying so to speak with with us
organisms and we don't know yet um is it
conceivable yes I think it's conceivable
I mean people the very fact that was
discovered what what is it 15 years ago
20 years ago of how to no 15 years ago I
think of how to go back from a a sort of
a a specific cell to something that is a
stem cell that has the potentiality to
turn into to lots of different kinds of
cells that was only discovered fairly
recently and I know there are
experiments going on of can you kind of
cure aging by just sort of having cells
uh be be fresh cells in some way and you
know there there are things where you
say let's you know when there's cells
that didn't make it and that one kind of
became senescent you know when that when
that cell was um uh sort of died off
let's get rid of those cells and then
maybe they'll be more cells get produced
that that don't have those same aging
characteristics I think um that
uh uh you know but but it's also the
case it's very strange thing that there
is so many clocks in bi biology I mean
the thing that always is is a little
shocking to me is you use a facial
feature recognizer like the one we have
on W language and it'll tell you you
know it takes picture of you and it'll
tell you how old you are and it's like
really you know and it gets it right
quite accurately I mean I I was thinking
for me for a while that I might have
been in the training set for the for the
machine learning classifier that figures
out ages but but I don't think that's
what's going on I think uh what is going
on what's going on is that there are
gradual changes in facial structure just
as there are gradual changes you know
eventually they by the time you're like
40 years old or something the plates of
the skull fuse and so on there are
things that happen over the course of
many decades and which sort of
inexorably happen and which by the way
the AI can notice even though we humans
don't so readily notice these things and
so that's sort of an inexorable clock
through life now that particular thing
of of moving around facial features and
so on and you know pieces of cartilage
getting bigger and whatever else is is
probably not relevant to whether you
live or not but it's certainly a a kind
of a a sort of a reminder of the fact
that there is an intrinsic biological
clock and what is needed to divert that
biological clock we don't know I mean
and of course with things like tumors
the what's happening there is that sort
of the usual of clocking and limitations
on growth and so on that exist in
biological organisms they have been they
have been removed and we're kind of back
to a form of life before we had sort of
individual organisms that grew to fixed
size it's just like just keep growing
and that turns out not to be very
compatible with uh you know with
organisms that were at our stage in The
evolutionary process so to speak so you
know but what it takes to get into
something which sort of grows like us
but doesn't go out of control like that
it's almost one of these undecidability
problems you set up a certain set of
conditions in your molecular biology is
it going to be something which sort of
does the right thing or is it going to
do something computationally irreducible
and unexpected and do the wrong thing
and for example start sort of growing
forever or some other bad thing like
that but
so you know I think look in the end
there will be human immortality I I I'll
be I don't think there's any fundamental
reason to think that that's impossible
what exactly it will mean and how much
is sort of turned over in that process
if it what it means is you kind of get
to have a biological organism that sort
of has the same memories and can
remember from 300 years ago and so on um
my guess is that will happen and uh how
much of that will have been sort of oh
and you by the way have a digital sort
of assist that's connected to you know
forget having uh actual organ X let's
just have the the uh uh the kind of
technological version of organ X why why
bother to have an actual liver or
something just have this kind of
artificial one that um uh sort of plugs
into the is plug compatible with the
biological one and maybe much of what
you have ends up being that that um uh
artificial technological solution and
then you have to ask what does it mean
to have human immortality in the case
where almost everything has been
replaced by something that isn't really
terribly human and of course that gets
even more complicated when you're
replacing pieces of brains by sort of
the the digital assist so to speak or
the neural net the artificial neural net
that sort of oh yes well you know you're
something went wrong with some piece of
the hypothalamus so we replaced it with
some artificial hypothalamus and then
you know and then it's like how far does
that go and at what point do you have
human immortality versus essentially uh
just or I say just but it might be uh
you know that this this um quotes
artificial this technological
immortality you know I'm certainly
hoping as a as a person who's getting
old myself I certainly hope that uh the
advances that might
happen that would get one to the point
where you know the the life expectancy
is increasing at more than more than one
year per year so to speak so that you so
that it sort of goes to Infinity um that
that happens uh sort of soon enough to
not uh you know to to not sort of exit
oneself it would be great I mean you
know the other the other opportunity is
the whole cryonic story and the ability
to sort of have a pause in uh and sort
of freeze everything until for a better
day so to speak I I think the challenge
with all of these things the challenge
with that one is the discontinuity of
experience may you know what what as you
know if one's been around and exposed to
the way that technology is evolving and
so on we're not that you know one isn't
you know if if you took the me from 1965
or something and brought me to today
there'd be lots of things where I just I
have no idea how this works what the
heck is this um it's uh you know the
world has changed because of Technology
primarily a little bit because of social
kinds of Dynamics as well but um uh one
might sort of say some things that will
be terrible today or say some things
that will be Charming today from you
know jumping from 1965 or something but
I think that uh you know that Dynamic of
um of kind of you know if you are
continually around and sort of paying
attention to the the development of the
world you're going to to be sort of
still in your time if you kind of were
frozen for 100 years and then come back
then you're not in your time and it's
not completely clear how that plays
out let's
see sumof comments would it make sense
for alien AI civilizations to broadcast
radio or other signals with information
about how to build an AI that can
propagate a universe faster than materal
space travel yes but you know the thing
that's so difficult is it's so hard to
go outside of one's current human
purpose you know the things that have
been sort of you know bashed into us by
our struggle for life in biological
evolution etc etc etc it's so hard to
kind of go to the the kind of the
abstract purpose of you know now you
know it has to be said that if your if
whatever you do causes you to not exist
then there's nothing more to say so
there is a certain sense in which sort
of the propagation of something and
making more of it exist is a
self-fulfilling thing that has to happen
so you know I suppose that's an argument
for why the I mean you know one could
say that um let's see what will be an
extreme thing to say one could say that
um look you know all of the um
what could I say something like all of
the interstellar grains that have all
these particular molecules on them that
um we can um uh uh you know that that we
get uh radio signals that show us that
this molecule exists and a slightly
weird molecule we never bothered to look
at before exists gosh golly there must
be a you know an Intergalactic
conspiracy or at least Interstellar
conspiracy that's putting these
particular molecules on these grains
that we will detect and that we'll say
gosh that's an interesting molecule
let's go make that molecule here now
that isn't our usual interpretation our
usual interpretation is it's just
physics that's putting these molecules
on these Interstellar grains but I think
that this it's just physics argument is
a complicated one because look at what
our brains do it's just physics it's
physics where we say it's packaged in a
way that's very special to us etc etc
Etc but at some level it's just
physics all right maybe one more
question or
comment
uh bunch of comments here about
um uh diminishing returns Fu says
related to AI machine learning
um H comments AI will create this time
of Step function upwards and
everything um but that may not be the
case due to diminishing
returns yeah well I
think it's an interesting question to
what extent you know what we've seen
sort of observationally in the
Technologies we've seen you know the big
jump in 2012 with with um identification
and so on image
processing slightly less heralded big
jumps in speech to text for example big
jumps and language generation and so on
it seemed like they they keep on being
these sort of jumps where something gets
to the point where it wasn't possible
and now it's possible and you know
there's the question of well you there's
a certain set of things we humans do and
we can kind of check them off could we
do that one could we do that one and so
on and I think the uh uh and then
there's the question well what about the
things we humans don't do right now and
that's where things get challenging
because you know it's very easy to make
a computational system that does a lot
of stuff that we humans don't do problem
is it's not clear we humans care about
it I mean in my life I've spent quite a
lot of it studying rology kind of the
the study of simple rules and what they
do kind of what's out there in the
computational universe your average you
know cell automaton with all these rules
very simple rules often very complicated
Behavior you look at it and I say that's
pretty interesting I but I can't really
humanize it very well I can't really say
and that's why you know it makes my you
know me have a better lunch type thing
it's um it's much more abstracted from
that and I think this question about
once we've we we know there are certain
things we humans do now there's the
question of what else is out there in
the computational universe and there's a
lot out there in the computational
universe but the the history of
civilization the history of sort of
intellectual history is about making
these small moves away from what we've
already done sort of building on the
tower we've already built then we go to
the next step and there's this sort of
vast expanse out there of what's
computationally possible and most of it
we humans as of today would look at it
and just s of shrug and say we don't
care I mean I I think we care because I
care about rology and studying this
computational universe and sort of the
the science of that but in general in
term I would not be able to say that
there sort of immediate everyday
applications of what you see out in the
computational universe except things
that are pretty close to where we've
already gone so far so I think this
question of of sort of you know can the
AIS do you know they go out into the
computational universe what do they find
I think the limiting factor there is
mostly what do we humans care about that
is we can and that becomes sort of the
what are the humans going to do well the
AIS can zoom off in any direction you
know the AIS are you know fast driving
cars or something but it's not
particularly useful to have a fast
driving car unless you have a you know
unless there's a human driver who's
deciding where the car should go I mean
the disembodied fast driving car can
zoom off in random Direction in the
desert or something but it's it's like
the humans are probably going to say who
cares um the the you know the the thing
the place where the humans fit in is in
this you know so which direction do we
want to drive in and I think that's
something where when people wonder sort
of how do humans fit in to the world of
AIS yes the AIS can provide the fast
driving cars but it's still got to be
kind of one's got to have choices which
are for us humans in so far as we are we
care about how we what we perceive in
the world world that has to be
determined by what uh by kind of what we
humans choose so to speak so I think
um uh you know they're both practical
technological things about these
thresholds associated with different
kinds of things you can do then there
are these kind of so what does one care
about doing that one gets into and uh
you know I I do think it's still sort of
an open question if in the what does one
care about doing
we care about for example making human
language let's say there's another level
of of thing there that is I don't know
you know let's say you have sensory
information not from just you and your
eyes and your fingers and so on but you
have sensory information in detail about
the whole world now in a sense we
already have that because you know we're
looking at the web and so on and we're
getting uh you know live streams from
all over the place and all that kind of
thing but let's say we were able to kind
of have sensory information sensory
input that really was looking at every
you know Internet of Things sensor
everywhere in the world and maybe
there's a different level of kind of
description that we can start to apply
you know human language maybe we could
say is relevant if what we're talking
about is the kinds of things that we as
sort of humans walking around and you
know whatever you know about you know
five and a half feet tall or whatever it
is um you know that that um that we
experience but there's a quite different
level of thing that's kind of a super
not language like but who knows what it
is some some way of organizing things
that's relevant if you are seeing every
every sensor in the in in the world so
to speak I mean it's kind of uh you
might say there are certain kinds of
things that are worth thinking about if
you have eyes and you're getting so
visual data different things if you only
have touch for example
all right I better go back to my day job
here um but uh thank you for a lot of
interesting questions and comments today
and um got me to think about a bunch of
things I haven't thought properly about
before so thanks very much and uh look
forward to chatting again another time
bye for
now